joining us here on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line from uh the new england
patriots getting set to play monday
night football
against the buffalo bills to wrap up
week number 13 in the nfl is none other
than a long time pro in his 12th season
out of rutgers right now for the new
england patriots devin mccordy how you
doing devon
i'm doing all right man how you doing
i'm doing fine i appreciate you just
joining us fresh off the practice field
right now um you've been around some
championship teams there sir
um and you've been around some teams
that have gotten hot and then made the
super bowl is this one of those teams do
you think
i don't know man i would say all those
teams that i've been on i would say in
the process we didn't know and i would
say some of those teams um you know we
had some you know tough times some
adversity i hit um where if you look
back there were a lot of people doubting
and saying there was no chance of that
so um i think all those teams though had
one thing about they were willing to
work hard and not worry about you know
everything else that was going on
outside but just kind of focus on the
team and that's what we've been
preaching here all year obviously
starting two or four
wasn't ideal but i think the mentality
of all the guys in this locker room
are staying focused on each other
staying focused on the team um has uh
enabled us to go on a little bit of a
win streak and i think you've heard it
you know i think in the last few weeks
from a lot of different players we want
to keep that mentality and we want to
keep that going so that's the plan so
then what what i i have seen this isn't
my first rodeo with the nfl as you know
i have seen many patriots teams
certainly on defense play this way
before but it usually
uh it's right around now when it begins
to jail because so many guys who come in
new uh don't understand or conceive of
what the do your job mentality is and
how this defense works but you guys have
been balling out for
weeks why
would you say devin um
i think it's just a combination of you
know guys understanding their roles guys
going out there and doing it and i think
the biggest part that we've done a
better job at you know comparative
beginner season is situational football
and all the key situations uh call it
two minute where we know their pass and
they have to pass they know it um
they're making the big plays or we need
the ball back we need to get a stop uh
and they're up and they have the lead
and us getting to stop i think those
situations where as a defense you know i
don't think we were always clicking and
you know everybody understanding where
the next guy was going to be i think we
struggled a little bit early in the
season we've gotten better at that i
think trust builds from week to week and
guys trust each other playing fast
playing hard and i think it's paying off
so it's not just i think the physical
game i think even mentally we've
understood how we want to play the game
better and i think that's paid off a lot
for us but it also helps devin mccordy
here on the rich eisen show prior to
monday night football it also helps that
you're not being put out there on a
short field this offense and also you're
also not being thrown out there um two
minutes after you get off the field i
mean this offense has been sustaining
drives this offense has not been turning
it over it's been efficient they do
score they also run the ball very well
and a lot of it has to do with with
obviously you know where i'm going with
this with mac jones when did you first
realize he had
it
devin uh i think well i think um in
training camp i think everyone saw that
you know his focus um how he was
preparing how he took the field reading
defense i think everyone uh was fully
comfortable with him taking the field
and being our guy
um the whole it factor and all of that i
think that's all him i think he's
developed that i think he's worked hard
um to have that and i think you know for
us as a team it's been awesome just to
play together and play complimentary
football i think you know everyone's
talked about how the defense is played
in the beginning of the season different
things like that but i think the biggest
reason that we've been able to play
better is all three phases playing
together and obviously with back in the
offense those guys understand how they
want to play each week and you know
special teams nothing helps us out more
i think you saw even our game last week
you know we started kickoff we pinned
tennessee back because of a holding call
because of you know our kickoff team but
cody then we get a three and out you
know
gunner gets a great return after a
penalty then our offense has a short
field they go down and score and i think
that's how we've played that's how we
won games it's just a combination of all
three phases playing together um and i
think we know that's our recipe for
success um but we can't let that change
well i mean you also know
it's a quarterback driven league not
only because of the you know the fact
you play defense but you've been around
uh you know and winning championships
with the greatest of all time and it's
very difficult to compare new england
offenses certainly with a rookie because
of that alone that's my wind up with
this pitch devin
and that is what similarities do you see
between mack and his predecessor and
brady you got any there has to be some
i can't man i i i wouldn't do that to
the young man i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna compare him to that guy but i do
think um he's coming here with a real
professional uh mentality he doesn't he
doesn't feel like a rookie when it comes
to the preparation part talking about
the game i think he's come with that and
you know i think part of that is you
know what he did at alabama those guys
are always playing for championships the
other guys that play quarterback in
front of them are all in the nfl right
now so it's you know i don't think
anything is new to him of what we're
trying to do as a team and i think
that's really paid off for us um and i
think he he's just uh focused a lot on
what he needs to do in himself um and i
think a lot of us as older guys kind of
told him like don't change that you know
that's how you become a good player in
this league keep doing those things and
uh you know your colleague i had matthew
jude on on a couple weeks ago uh devin
mccourty and i'm sorry to hear that
well this is before he trashed mac and
cheese uh devin you know this is before
all that i wouldn't have him on after
that comment obviously um but uh when i
had him on he mentioned i mentioned mac
he talked about the spirit that he takes
coaching with and how that was something
he noticed and has been noticed by
everyone on the team i'm wondering what
about you
yeah definitely i think um i think
that's the one position too in this
league where you know egos and different
things like that play a factor and for
him it hasn't you know i think he's
taken coaching really well um and even
you know i think for us we i remember
just talking to him about safety plan
and quarterback play um and how much you
know those two positions are reading
each other and trying to understand each
other um and it was it was great just
talking to him and understanding the
different things he sees and me telling
him some of the things that i've learned
over the years of what affects the
quarterback and some reads that have
helped me get good reads on quarterbacks
when you know trying to throw the ball
down the field so he's always been open
to that and i think it's been great for
him
just with the experience around him
obviously with josh and you know some of
those guys we have on offense with
hunter and guys like that they've been
around different quarterbacks they've
been in the league for a while um and i
think that's helped a lot you know when
you talk about developing and you know
seeing different things and getting an
experience i think that's helped him a
lot all right in a couple of minutes i
have left with you devin mccourty first
one uh i got two more questions for you
first one i'm going to go on that third
rail direction which is making you talk
about your coach bill belichick but
you've been around okay you've been
there for 12 years um
do you think he's got a little bit of a
reinvigoration
because of what's happening this year
after last year that mac jones is there
that you seem to be back on the patriot
way track based on somebody who's just
watching it
do you see belichick in any different
way this year
devin um i wouldn't say different but i
would say last year
um left a bad chase in everybody's
mouth con it was it wasn't what we
wanted it wasn't the expectation it
wasn't the standard um and i think all
of us kind of walked out of here last
year after that last game against the
jets i'm happy that we won the game but
also that feeling of like well we don't
want to be living this way again like we
don't want that and i think bill
definitely has had that approach you
know i think you know no one wants to be
on a losing team and you know like you
said it's my 12th year here i've i never
had to experience that and for him he's
been here for 20 something years and
they've done a lot of winning um so i
don't think anybody enjoyed last year i
think it was definitely
a sense of urgency and a focus on you
know making this year different making
this year better and you know so far it
has been but uh still a lot of football
left to be played and you know i think
you know like i know with bill you know
all of this is great but he he's locked
in on what we need to do monday night
right um that's all that's all he's
gonna talk about that's gonna be his
focus yeah and it's just a week-to-week
league and he is one of the greatest
ever in that week-to-week league just
focusing on the week and in that regard
you are going to wrap up week 13
in a game for the division and
technically for the conference you're
playing for the division and the
conference and we just already
established you didn't play in the
playoffs last year so the challenge for
this week is is what for you devon
mccourty in buffalo i think that i think
to stay focused on buffalo i think
especially in a year where like you just
said you know
we had no shot last year around this
time you know you weren't playing for
much or anything and i think now um not
taking that for granted and
understanding how how great of an
opportunity this is to just be playing
for something um i think we got to make
sure we don't get wrapped up in that and
lose sight of you know keeping josh
allen in the pocket making sure that we
can change uh all of these skill guys
whether it's diggs beasley davis comes
in the game knocks uh sanders keeping
those guys in front of us uh in front of
us and not giving up the big play not
turning the ball over on offense i think
those key things that we're going to
need to do to win the game is what we
need to stay focused on not you know
where we'll be if we lose or where we'll
be if we win just focus on the keys and
the things we talk about all week
that'll help us win the game i think
that'll put us where we need to be but
um you know i think this is one of those
weeks and we're at that point in the
season where every game means more and
everybody i want to talk about you know
a whole lot of other things other than
the execution of the game plan in the
game and i think we got to make sure
that we don't let that control us and we
just control the things that we need to
do uh play our roles and do our jobs so
i'm playing the patriots defense and
special teams in my fantasy league this
week correct i'm doing that i don't even
i don't know much about fantasy but i'm
a patriots fan
so then do me a favor well just to wrap
this up when you see bill belichick hey
tell him i said hello and b i'm going to
play the patriots uh defense and special
teams this week in my fantasy league so
uh i'm counting on him
very high i will will
definitely let him know i'm sure he's
curious about it so please do that
devon thanks for the time sir thank you
appreciate it
you bet that is three-time super bowl
champion and current new england patriot
devin mccourty right here on the rich
eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here